Mike Tyson's back in the fight but this  time in the Octagon EA Sports announced  the legendary boxer Mike Tyson will be a  playable character in EA sports UFC to a  mixed martial arts game you'll need to  act fast if you want to play as Mike  though he's available only as a  pre-order bonus two versions of Mike  Tyson will be playable first Iron Mike  Tyson modeled after Mike's glory years  when he went 50 and six with 44  knockouts and second legacy Mike Tyson  complete with that iconic tribal tattoo  on his face that you may have seen in  the hangover or that hoverboard video EA  sports UFC 2 is set to launch on March  15 for Xbox one and PlayStation 4 stay  tuned to gamespot for your daily gaming  news